que el sistema de desigualdades
representa mejor la gráfica que se
muestra a continuación
queremos encontrar que desigualdades
describen mejor esta área sombreada una
buena manera de comenzar es encontrar
las ecuaciones de estas dos líneas que
limitan esta área hagamos primero esta
que se ve más difícil porque tiene un
ángulo escribimos la ecuación de una
línea la ecuación general de una línea
es de igual a m por x + b donde b es la
intersección en sí y m es la pendiente
así que trataremos de encontrar la
ecuación de esta línea cuál va a ser su
pendiente tomemos un punto cuando yo me
muevo o me desplazo en x la incrementó x
cuanto se incrementen ya vemos este
punto y llega allí se incrementa en dos
unidades también
si yo me desplazo en x aumento una
unidad
y también va a aumentar una unidad así
que la pendiente es 1 la pendiente es el
cambio en y entre el cambio en x
y aquí el cambio es 12 x y el cambio es
12 y 2 entre 2 va a ser igual a 1 cual
es la intersección en cuales b pues
vemos cuál es el valor de esta línea
cuando x es 0 y está justamente acá ve
en esta línea va a ser igual a 1 por lo
que la ecuación de esta línea va a ser
igual a g
igual queremos que la pendiente es 1 así
que es x
más bebés uno más uno esa es la ecuación
de esta línea que tiene un ángulo pero
noten que la región sombreada se
encuentra debajo de esta línea y no la
incluye como sé que no la incluye porque
aquí está dibujada con una línea
punteada si fuera una línea sólida
entonces yo sabría que se incluye la
línea que limita esta área pero como es
una línea punteada no la va a incluir
puede pensar en esto de la siguiente
manera si tenemos para x igual a 1 este
x1
el valor en la línea base es aquí 2 las
'íes' que nos interesan del área
punteada se encuentran por encima
de este valor por debajo pues obviamente
se encuentran por debajo y no le
incluyen así que las 10 que me interesan
de esta área las yes deben ser menores
que esta ecuación de la línea x más 1
menores pero no iguales porque no
incluyen la línea pero aún no hemos
terminado esta sería la solución si el
área gris estuviera completamente por
debajo de toda la línea pero sólo esté
asombrado hasta cierto punto hasta donde
se intersecta con esta otra línea esta
línea de aquí abajo es muy sencilla no
tiene pendiente no importa el valor de x
siempre el valor de y será el mismo así
que si la pendiente es 0 cuál va a ser
la ecuación de esta línea de esta línea
de acá
su ecuación y igual la pendiente que
vemos que es cero así que no va a haber
nada en x
es igual a b la intersección en la
intersección de esta línea
es menos 2 es igual a menos 2 y
analizamos el área gris que me interesa
donde se encuentra con respecto a esta
línea por encima o por abajo
pues se encuentra por encima los valores
en llevan a estar por encima de este
valor de esta línea así que los valores
que me interesan del ayer van a ser
mayores a menos dos mayores y no iguales
porque esa también es una línea punteada
me indica que no se incluyen los valores
que están en esta línea si yo quisiera
restringir el área sombreada con solo
esta línea el área gris sería todo lo
que está por encima de ella pero lo que
quiero es la combinación de ambas líneas
para tener mi área gris que es bien
mayor a menos 2 y menor a x + 1 esta es
mi solución veamos cuáles son las
opciones que tengo para estas soluciones
entonces queremos que nuestra solución
que va a ser mayor que menos 2 y mayor
que menos 2 g menor que menos dos de
entrada puedo decir que estas dos no me
aplican
estas dos no son soluciones
mayor a los dos puede ser cualquiera de
estas dos ahora quedamos que ya es menor
que x más uno y mayor que x más uno
esta no es mi solución es b
mayor que menos 2 y menor que x1
veamos el siguiente problema
al punto está en el conjunto de
soluciones para el sistema siguiente 2
x mayor o igual que menos 6 y 12 menos 3
x menor que menos 6 básicamente queremos
que ver cuál de estos puntos cumple con
ambas desigualdades en este sistema
podemos graficar ambas líneas y ver cuál
punto queda entre ambas
o podemos simplemente probar los valores
vamos a hacer esto la primera opción es
menos cuatro menos uno aquí en estos
pares ordenados este está es la
coordenada en x y esta va a ser la
coordenada en g
vamos a tomar estos valores y
sustituirlos en estos sistemas de
ecuaciones así que en este caso de la
opción
tomamos menos 4 y lo sustituimos en
donde está x el menos 1 en donde están
las 2 porque va a ser dos por menos uno
menos x x es menos 4 debe ser mayor o
igual a menos 6
aquí es 2 x menos 1 - 2 - x menos es más
+4 mayor o igual a menos 6 menos dos más
4 es igual a 2 y 2 es mayor o igual que
menos 6 esto sí se cumple ahora tomemos
estos valores pero lo sustituimos en
esta otra ecuación aquí es 2
por qué es menos 1 - 1 - 3 x xx es menos
424 debe ser menor a menos 62 x menos 1
- 2 - 3 x menos 4 es más 12 y eso debe
ser menor que menos 6 menos dos más 12
es 10 y 10 no es menor que menos 6 así
que éste no se cumple a no es hagamos lo
mismo pero ahora con los valores en vez
vamos a separar esto para probar los
valores de esta otra opción 3 es x 1 es
de 2 x 2 x 1 - x que es 3 lo está
sustituyendo en esta primera desigualdad
mayor igual a menos 62 por una es 2 - 3
mayor o igual a menos 62 menos 3 - 1
es mayor o igual que menos 6 es así se
cumple ahora para la segunda ecuación 2
porque quedamos que es uno menos 3 por x
x estrés es menor que menos 62 por 1 2
- 3 x 3 es menos 9
menor a menos 62 menos 9 es igual a
menos 7 que es menos 7 es menor a menos
6 así que esta si se cumple ya no tengo
que buscar más la solución a este
problema es la opción b y ahora veamos
el tercer problema de este vídeo que el
sistema de desigualdades lineales está
representado en la siguiente gráfica
aquí podemos aplicar las habilidades que
aprendimos en el problema anterior
analicemos la línea que se encuentra
aquí a la derecha de esta parte superior
tenemos de encontrar su pendiente vamos
a ver cuánto se incrementa que si yo
incremento x
esta x la incrementó 3
unidades
de este punto de x que acaba de
incrementar mi punto en jet también se
incrementó tres unidades
3 aquí en lesaka si yo aumento x en 2
unidades
michelle también va a aumentar en dos
unidades el cambio entre el cambio en x
o lo que es lo mismo mi pendiente va a
ser igual a 1
y cuál es la intersección en que bueno
buscamos cuando x es igual a cero el
valor de esta línea está aquí en menos 2
la pendiente es 1 y b es igual a menos 2
por lo que la ecuación de esta línea de
acá está de acá va a ser igual a igual a
la pendiente m 1 va a ser x + b qué es
22 esa es la ecuación de esta línea el
área sombreada está por debajo de la
línea y aquí noten que si tengo una
línea sólida no es línea punteada así
que los valores incluyen los que se
encuentran en esta línea ahora
analicemos la línea de la izquierda esta
línea de acá veamos cuál es su ecuación
esta línea luce más interesante qué pasa
si yo incremento mi x en 1 si tomo este
valor
de x lo incremento acá donde va a estar
la y pues que cree en la ya no va a
aumentar la y va a incrementarse y va a
decrementar se en dos unidades aquí fue
un 1 que aumente y aquí está bajando en
2 - 2
si yo incremento x en 2 por ejemplo aquí
si el aumento en 2 unidades
me va a bajar cuatro unidades estos son
dos que aumente y se me decremento
cuatro unidades así que la pendiente de
esta otra línea la pendiente
el cambio en que es -4 entre el cambio
en x que fue de 2
mi pendiente menos 4 entre 2 es menos 2
este es mi pendiente de esta otra línea
y la intersección en que cuando x es
igual a 0
es aquí entonces ve de esta otra línea
de esta otra ecuación va a ser igual a 3
la ecuación de esta línea de acá
es igual queremos que la pendiente es
menos dos menos 2x
más ve que es 33 y dónde está el área
sombreada con respecto a esta línea de
acá pues está por encima de esta línea
incluyendo la porque tenemos una línea
sólida aquí así que las ecuaciones que
me sirven para distinguir o especificar
esta área sombreada son quedamos que la
primera línea es las diez son menores a
esta línea incluyendo las entonces mi
primera solución es de menor o igual a
x2 y de esta otra línea queremos que las
10 están por encima incluyendo las de la
ecuación así que aquí me va a ser mayor
o igual a menos 2 x más 3
es mi sistema de ecuaciones de solución
veamos las opciones tenemos estas
opciones vemos estas dos opciones donde
ya es menor o igual que x2 y aquí tiene
que es mayor o igual que x menos dos
esta opción no es de hecho voy a ponerlo
en otro color para que se note esta
opción no es y aquí ya mayor o igual a 2
x + 3 no aquí está igual a mayor o igual
a menos 2 x + 3 así que ésta tampoco es
estas como que están en un formato
diferente voy a tener que tendré que
reacomodar estas ecuaciones para
poderlas comparar y ver cuál es mi
opción solución muy bien voy a tomar
esta primera ecuación y voy a
multiplicar todo por menos 1 entonces va
a ser menos 1 por menos de cómo estoy
multiplicando por menos 1 voy a cambiar
sentido de la desigualdad y va a ser
mayor igual x x menos 1 es menos x
y menos dos por menos sólo va a ser
igual a más dos y ahora voy a sumar x en
ambos lados de la desigualdad x menos y
mayor o igual a 2 ya quiere como de
todos los elementos xy para que queden
en un lado en esta ecuación y ahora
veamos la siguiente esta voy a sumar
+ 2 x en ambos lados de la desigualdad
así que de ésta va a ser 2 x más mayor o
igual a 3 y ahora si ya tenemos todos
los elementos ordenados y comparamos con
estas dos opciones 2 x + mayor o igual
que a 3 y esto es 2 x menos así que ésta
no es y vemos que nuestra opción de es x
menos mayor o igual a 2 2 x más mayor o
igual a 3 y esta es nuestra opción
solución